being back in New York reminds me how
New Yorkers do not hide their emotions
and your hero a lot obviously and I find
that to be quite refreshing a little
scary sometimes but very refreshing it's
nice because when people are all acting
nice
you got it soon that they're lying human
nature's to be a little bit all the time
you know but I like I was in a house
watch I was in a shopping for groceries
and I looked over and there's a woman
standing over there and as I looked over
she looked away in a way that I knew
she'd been looking at me the whole time
and she went like like that just looking
at me like uh and then I'm walking in
another aisle same store and some guy
saw me and he looked me up and down I
went ah he just and I was like I know
but how do you know you know what's
coming through so anyway then I was on
the subway and I'm standing on the
subway and I have to stand up to show
you I'm standing on the subway like this
this is me on the subway and there's a
person here you know this is my
corresponding you yours the stander and
there's your sitter looker at dicker
there just right there I mean that's
what they had no choice they're sitting
like this and you're standing over
I mean women are decent and they stand
like sideways we just go like but anyway
he's instead usually they tune out your
dick like this but he's looking right at
it right here so he's looking and he's
kind of looking at it like what's up
with that yeah and then he looks up at
me and he goes and that's not that makes
me uncomfortable and then he goes points
right at my dick and then I realized I
looked down at my fly's open
not only not only is it open it's
aggressively it's like it's not like a
pants like a slit like a pants vagina
it's like a like a grizzly bears [ __ ]
that would be and
so as soon as some you know and now my
whole world turns upside down I love
this man I love him very much because he
told me I'm walking around all day and
people are judging me
they look at me like uh like this is a
choice like a person goes out yeah you
know what today I'm just gonna
how do you have anything but pity for
somebody right right I did right and as
soon as somebody tells you your fly's
down your first thought is how long yeah
how long have I been walking around with
this confident face that doesn't match
[Laughter]
you